[Musique]
il faut des stars
le charme en australie c'est un peu
comme notre pétrole au canada c'est une
industrie qui fait 870 le travailleur
qui vous parle qu un ministre comme
inspecteur de l'avenir déjà quand scott
morrison était ministre des finances et
le défendrai jusqu'au tapis freins et du
corps le stralis c'est d'ailleurs le
deuxième exportateur de charbon au monde
en même temps c'est une source d'énergie
qui est extrêmement polluant la plus
sale qui existent même selon des
scientifiques et s'il ya un mais deux
projets de mines qui représente bien que
cette division
c'est celui d'abel à dany c'est une
multinationale indienne qui veut prendre
du charbon dans le queensland dans le
nord-est de l'australie pour l'exporter
vers des pays d'asie pour l'instant à
dany dit qu'elle va extraire 10 millions
de tonnes de charbon par année dès 2021
mais elle a été autorisée par le
gouvernement australien à se rendre
jusqu'à 60 millions si c'est le cas et
ça en ferait la plus grosse mine de
charbon dans l'hémisphère sud
[Musique]
on vient d'arriver à l'entrée du site de
construction de la mine à dany mais
c'est vraiment difficile de constater
l'impact de ce projet là parce que c'est
la seule chose qu'a dany nous permet de
voir du site
ils ont fusé nos demandes d'entrevue et
nos demandes de tournage aussi sur le
site la construction ici vient tout
juste de débuter
pendant qu'on tourner des images à
l'entrée du site sur la voie publique
un garde de sécurité nous interdire le
gardien commence à prendre des photos de
notre véhicule
on est sur une voie publique l'on est
sur une route publique
mais on vient de se faire déranger par
quelqu'un pour le mans donc là il ya
maintenant deux gardes de sécurité
les camionnettes de sécurité se
multiplient jusqu'à temps qu'on
s'éloigne du site
finalement on n'aura pas vu grand-chose
la future mine dany en fait c'est grâce
à ces images de drones prise par une
organisation pour la conservation du
territoire qu'on peut mieux imaginer
comment l'état vont être complètement
transformé ont décidé à ce moment là de
se rendre à la ville la plus proche qui
est à plus de 200 km c'est clairement
une communauté qui vit du charbon
mais ce n'est pas le pasteur allen kelly
qui est en chemin vers la messe lui a
deux fils qui travaille dans l'industrie
sismique a mano ap7 gallo fait révèle in
sound system inde alors de overweight et
à l'orgue progressistes au nahd
[Musique]
la raison tu dessines mais climat est
tellement sec qui doit puiser l'eau des
nappes souterraines pour que ces machos
qui existent ici qu'ils croient qu'à
dalli va détruire
même si l'entreprise lui a dit qu'il
n'avait rien à craindre ils redoutent en
creusant la mine à dany fracturé les
structures sous terre et empêche ensuite
l'autre circuler normalement pour les
fermiers mais il n'y a pas de défi remis
des environs de la mine qui s'inquiète
le plan d'analysé transporter son
charbon par train jusqu'à la côte et
jusqu'aux terres ancestrales des zhu une
communauté aborigène forêt
carol prieur une leader djourou estime
qu'elle devra avoir un droit de regard
sur le projet à dany s'est entendu avec
certains chefs aborigènes mais pas tous
thomas jordan à l'irish examiner
il ya un autre enjeu important
ces peurs qu'à gagner à acheter pour
exporter son charbon qui débouchent sur
la mer de corail
[Musique]
même si les bateaux remplis de charme
monde à niveau ont emprunté des passages
très réglementé les environnementalistes
craie et reese le déversement
et puis quand le charbon de la minstre
brûlé et produira jusqu'à 79 millions de
tonnes de co2 par année l'équivalent des
émissions annuelles de plus de 5
millions de canadiens
de quoi fragiliser encore plus le corail
qui a blanchi massivement depuis cinq
ans à cause du réchauffement de l'eau
ramène un parking de riffs euros aux
lentilles jeunes
en australie on sent vraiment que le
charbon polarise comme au canada et deux
positions très campi époux de piste de
réconciliation
[Musique]